max bist du auch so wütend wie ich ja
warum was ist los ich kann mir das
ständig sehen und was ist mit dir kumpel
ich habe eine gute idee und kannte
niemanden dafür begeistern ich auch
aufblasbare rose was ist dann hätte ich
mache ein neues restaurant auf unter kv
bunte burda
das war eine blöde idee da ist viel
besser hallo leute hier ist wieder eure
mal wanne und willkommen zu einer neuen
folge wie schmeckt und ja heute machen
wir nicht nur krabbeln bürger sondern
die bunten krabben bürger aus bobbau aus
der folge eine gute idee zweiter sketch
fünfte folge zweite stadt und ich weiß
ihr habt euch die krabben bürger so sehr
gewünscht aber leider bin auch ich nicht
an die geheimformel gekommen aber ich
habe mich ein paar episoden
durchgeklickt und ein gutes mittelmaß
gefunden
die grundformel besteht aber aus holten
bulette salat käse zwiebeln tomaten
ketchups senftöpfchen brötchen und über
eine sache bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher
ich habe nämlich auf spawn spieler
gelesen dass die bulette aussee fältchen
fleisch besteht und das wird ziemlich
krank vielleicht könnt ihr mir noch mehr
dazu sagen sie fertig und fleisch was
gab's bei uns döner mit pferdefleisch
oder lasagne mit pferdefleisch sei so
zeige ich euch heute wie man einem
letztlich mit pferde vielleicht macht
das wird es nicht gibt zuallererst
schneide ich die tomaten kleinen fertig
und jetzt noch alles andere klein
schneiden salatgurken ist fall ist die
geburt ungewichtete glücklichen rote
zwiebeln gramm bürger machen ist sollte
zu behalten
irgendwann später beruhigt habe ich mich
noch nicht aber wir machen jetzt reiter
match förder brötchen noch mehr bürger
brötchen traditionals scheller in
scheiben das ist ein irischer akzent
baustoff was ist das denn und farbstoff
anatol vegetarische pettys die definitiv
nicht aus seefeld hätte erst überlegt
burger pettys aus kidney bohnen selbst
machen aber das definitiv schneller und
zum abschluss natürlich ketchup und
selbst das ist ganz wichtig ich habe
einen grünen burger panel stand seien ja
so groß wie dieses petty und damit stand
die bürger brötchen aus denn beim
burgers alles ziemlich gleich und ich
stand mir das brötchen in der größe wie
ich den bürger brauche ich habe alle
brötchen auf einen
größe gestanzt und jetzt kommen wir zum
bürger fleisch seefeld dem fleisch werde
lasagne erstmal müssen wir den ofen und
damit meine ich den herd warm und da
muss natürlich in der zwischenzeit eure
bürger brötchen backen braten posten was
ihr am liebsten machen wollt ich mag es
im fußball auch in die pfanne
jetzt müssen die pds beraten und danach
sind sie schön knusprig muss bei pet
jemanden den namen paddy denken
petit petit mayonnaise nennen in unser
berger tätig sind jetzt fertig gebraten
und jetzt geht es ans belegt belegt
seine brötchen von folge zu folge anders
und deswegen habe ich jetzt meine
lieblings methode ausgesucht und das ist
aus der folge ein göttlicher bürger
steht er nämlich mit neptun im ring und
muss so viele krabben bürger wie möglich
machen
also zuerst nämlich die salat vom nehmen
wir hören
dann nehmen wir zu bibeln dann
komplettes burger partie
und jetzt kommt das süßeste zwei
brötchen so jetzt nehmen wir unseren
ketchup und macht ein süßes gewicht
drauf und gefällt war doch das ist
niemals umbringen werde sein auge
okay ich schaffe es nicht oh mein gott
ist das niedlich ganz wichtig ist jetzt
die kleine diese decke und damit decken
und es kommt noch eine
gute-nacht-geschichte die besten burger
macht man mit liebe nicht mit manchen es
war einmal eine kleine prinzessin
die wollte einen bürger haben und dessen
genannt gute nacht und am ende dennoch
ein kuss
[Musik]
ok kramer rollos fertig und jetzt machen
wir den zweiten krabben burger und ab
jetzt mache ich es in der originalen
drei folge brötchen boden bulette unter
wasser sonne aktivste käses wie bild
tomate wird senftöpfchen ist schon echt
gute bürger aber du hast die kirchen
vergessen 1200 und das ist meine
autoschlüssel und zum krönenden
abschluss chrome tsd
und ihr habt hier ist ein kramberger und
hier sind sie sechs leckere warme
comeback aber vanessa die sind doch
jetzt gar nicht bunt wie wie machst du
denn jetzt bunte kramberger daraus
nichts leichter als das zuerst nehmen
wir uns einen und dann eine sprühfarbe
für lebensmittel und jetzt machen wir
unseren krabben burger blau oma in gold
leute wir haben einen blauen bürger
lasst uns die anderen bürger anspruch
leute das sind sie meine bunten burger
ich raste aus guckt euch mal an wie gut
dass geworden ist das ist wie bei
spongebob das sind richtig bunte plastik
das ok max bist du bereit gewesen
ja es ist lebensmittelfarbe jetzt wird
uns der wichtigsten frage stellen wie
schmeckt max welche farbe möchtest du
roth auf 31 punkte burger 123
[Musik]
wurstsemmel schmeckt wie ein bürger
schmeckst du die farbe ein bisschen ich
finde auf partys kann man das echt gut
machen und konnte burger probiert es aus
wenn die worried meine damen bereich das
video gefallen hat und wenn nicht dann
schreibt mir dass ich besser machen kann
und schreibt mir auf jeden fall was ich
als nächstes vielleicht kochen soll also
wenn ihr noch andere videos sehen wollt
hier ist bestimmt noch 1 und da und hier
könnt ihr mich abonnieren
den braucht ihr gar nicht beachten
zwiebel schwert